Film Courage: How do you know a story is great? Stanley M. Brooks, Filmmaker/AFI Professor/Producer: Well
how do I know a story is great? That's a
good question. I have to trust my
instincts in my gut I think for me
spending a childhood and a high school
years and college years watching lots
and lots and lots of movies gave me a
film language and I think allows me to
spot a good story I've seen so many
really good movies and so many bad
movies and read so many scripts and so
many bad scripts that I think the
experience of that kind of indoctrinated
me to spotting something when it's
special I think if you the longer you
walk in the wilderness easier it's just
spot of forest or water I think and so
for me I have a very in-depth film
language from having watched endless
black and white movies from the 30s and
40s and 50s so I think that I mean if
swatched every movie on the AFI 100 for
example so I think that helps I think it
also helps recognize something that's
too similar to something or oh that's a
no Maj to and you know okay and neither
either they've done it well or they
haven't done it well and I you know
there's certain filmmakers like Billy
Wilder who who I would love to pattern
my directing career after who I admire
so deeply and so I think you know
following their instincts and reading
what they did what they thought
I think informs my decisions as well how
do you know if a script is ready for
financing wow that's a great question
how do I know a script is ready for
financing I got to pay bills I mean the
truth is I think it's you know it's real
subjective and I think it's instinct
because the truth is you know if you're
an editing room you could edit forever
there's no end to when it you need a you
need a delivery date deliberate rate in
two forms
and I think pressures and forges the
best movie you can make during that time
it's not open-ended and I think the same
is true with screenplays I think the
better screenplays are the ones that
have to be made within a time frame and
so at a certain point you have to sort
of say okay
this is the best we're gonna do to go
get the financing right now we can't
play with this for another year now is
the time just move this this has sort of
reached the time when it's either we're
not gonna make it we're not gonna send
it out or it's ready and I tended to I
think I tend to have a reputation of
sending in scripts to networks when I
was in the television movie business as
a producer that I could get behind so I
would not send it in much to the chagrin
of screenwriters often until I thought I
could defend it and if I couldn't defend
it then I would have the writer do more
work and if I could defend it then I
would send it in and there were a rare
occasion where the writer would do no
more work and was unwilling to to fix it
and and I think I scored a lot of points
because I would tell the network my
candid feelings so I wouldn't send
something in as a lot of my competitors
do and say everything's brilliant I
would send something in if the writer
hadn't done the work and say look this
is not in good shape I'm sending it to
you because I can't get the writer do
any more work but this isn't ready yet
normally I wouldn't show this to you so
you you are believer in multiple drafts
of notes and revisions things like that
Oh screenplays are not written they are
rewritten the best screenplays have been
rewritten and rewritten there is no such
thing as a brilliant first draft that
goes to screen unless maybe your David
Kelly but I mean that's know movies are
rewritten not written all of the
problems in the script get solved and
rewriting all of the character issues
gets solved and rewriting all the
production issues get solved and
rewriting you'd want to throw money at a
problem you want to solve it on the page
so yeah I'm a really big believer in yes
multiple drafts and then there's you
know there's again the draft that gets
your movie ordered and then there's the
draft that you shoot those are not the
same and then by the time it makes it to
the editing and it's on the timeline
it's the spoilers yeah that's totally
different different beast yep and so is
that one thing that you tell your
students is
to not be so precious with whatever was
the final version of the script versus
what
well I approve some students not
screenwriting well I have screeners as
well but primarily I'm teaching
producers and I critique their stuff
pretty strongly when they pitch in my
class so they don't have a choice
they can't be precious in my class do
you also teach them to have tough skin
yeah I there's a ten commandments that I
teach them on pitching and one of them
is be strong but take a punch you know
the truth is you want to be back in that
room again so even if they're passing
you want that experience to be positive
so you know even if they're saying no
find a good moment in that meeting so
that when you call back again a year
from now and you got another project
they don't go that was the guy that
fought with us so I think you want to
make sure that any pitching experience
is a good experience for both people
whether you sell or not the truth is you
know you're not gonna sell most of what
you know you only need you can get 99
noes as long as you get one yes so the
truth is you've got to be resumed you
got to get up off the man I think that
is I think there are producers that are
better at that than talented and that's
their skill is that they just are
relentless and doesn't matter how people
say no they just keep going they don't
care they have they are able to just get
knocked down and get back up and take a
punch from Mike Tyson and get back up
and take another punch with Mike Tyson
get back up I'm not that resilient I
take you know I take passes a little
more personal less so now than I did in
my early my career but yeah well I had
to learn how to have a tough skin but if
you if you're if you definitely can't
handle no and you're in the wrong
business well going back to Rain Man you
were told initially no and then you kept
going and obviously that worked yeah
with Rain Man we pitched it to Warner
Brothers and Warner Brothers said we
just bought a project similar to this
called Forrest Gump from Steve Tisch and
so we're not gonna buy your project and
we went out and pitched it take someone
else that we pitched the United Artists
and you know I said yes
and then there was the long gestation
after Dustin Hoffman and Tom Cruise
committed because we went through four
directors before we actually ended up
making the movie it was went through
Steven Spielberg and Marty breast and
Sydney Pollack before we ended up at
Barry Levinson so it was like four years
of rewriting and rewriting and rewriting
and then directors leaving the project
before we actually got it made
why do you think the industry saw it as
a competitor to Forrest Gump two
separate stories uh well the executive
at Warner Brothers saw it as similar
because it was about a mentally
challenged person whether they were
simple or actually truly artistic and so
after six long as Rain Man was so I
think that's why and they had bought a
book they apparently have pretty penny
for the book with Steve Tisch and so
they just decided even want to develop
now the irony is and I'm sure people one
of those don't forget that Forrest Gump
got made at Paramount and Raymond got
made at United Artists and they both won
Best Picture and either both got pitched
at Warner Brothers and both got passed
at Warner Brothers they developed a
script and Faris Gump and then didn't
make it and then they passed on the idea
of Raymond
you